[Music]
it's really fun to work with - we were
trying to figure out how many times
we've worked together and we're thinking
that this might be our seventh time like
we were counting it up and initially we
said five but as we were working we kept
coming up with more gigs that we had
done together it's really fun it takes a
long time to get painted sometimes I
wake up early but he works pretty fast
and not only that but it's always so
much fun to work with him that it
doesn't feel that long people it's in a
lot of details which I really appreciate
I feel like it really brings the whole
piece to life all the shadows and
highlights he puts in and all the extra
details you know I could tell he really
has an eye for that and it just feels
good to walk around in his work because
I know that it looks really good he
cracks a lot of jokes it's really fun I
guess the space that it takes to be a
body paint model you have to be able to
stay still for a really long time which
doesn't sound like a lot but then you
realize that people tend to fidget a lot
I'm pretty good at staying really still
for a while or moving around a lot for a
while but it's not always easy
especially if it's kind of cold in the
room but I get cold easily so like it's
nothing new to me the first time that I
was body painted by him it was live that
monster Palooza so I was a little
nervous to be honest
that hadn't done anything like that
before but at the same time I also
wasn't too nervous because I had seen
his work before already and I knew that
I liked it
so I knew that I had faith that it was
gonna turn out really great which it
totally did and I was so happy at set
that the AC was lasting so hard it is
actually like a different thing to wear
body paint art versus regular clothing
sometimes it makes people uncomfortable
or they might get a little judgy but you
know I don't really feel too
uncomfortable about it because for me
like you know parts that are supposed to
be censored are are covered anyways like
by pasties and
and things like that sometimes again it
gets a little uncomfortable like if
people are uncomfortable towards me it
makes me uncomfortable actually like if
they're totally comfortable and it
doesn't matter to me either but I feel
like sometimes their discomfort rubs off
on me a little but overall I'm pretty
comfortable if I'm at a convention I'm
usually in a group like I'm not the only
one painted so the eyes are a little
more distributed but it was still a fun
really great experience
[Music]
well this looks lovely though whoever
did this sign yeah thank you
yeah thanks god it's hot today
otherwise you feel like really chilly
right now yeah initially I didn't
want to look because you were naked
then I realized this is art and like art
should be appreciated you know like
through whatever mediums and maybe yeah
yeah I won't say it's okay I mean I
don't usually see women would I ever do
this myself
no you sort of appeared like a vision
just across the way and I would like wow
it's a look I have to admit I was like
I'm gonna look at your face for the most
part and now that I'm later like I'm a
little oh I'm gonna I'm gonna look now
yeah they're so yeah like they see
they're crazy like there's like a bunch
of different shades like the white oh
wow like the way that the colors blended
to each other it's like it was like it
looks like watercolor yeah
it actually would make me more
uncomfortable if I was like wearing a
swimsuit and they were staring at me
versus like them looking at me in the
body paint I'm wearing the body paint
and I know that that's something
different and unusual so like I know
that they're more looking at the details
because it's very complex there's many
layers of different colors so actually
in a way like someone examining you know
like swimsuit would actually make me
more uncomfortable versus into paint
it actually just makes me more
uncomfortable when they're really like I
can't look at you at all or if they're
like being judgmental that's when I get
really uncomfortable if they're like oh
my god you're naked
oh and like no I'm not it looks like a
skin type painting but not the more I
look at it I could tell it's just body
paint yeah I know there's been fresh his
teeth killing it yeah overall it was
kind of the general reactions that I
expected it's kind of like the reactions
that the general population gives like
at conventions and things if they're
like looking at the art like the details
it doesn't really make me uncomfortable
to be honest I actually wasn't that
surprised when people said that they
wouldn't try it because I had a lot of
gigs that I do people often come up to
me and they're you tell me like wow
you're so bold you're so brave I
couldn't do what you could do or either
they're not comfortable with themselves
or like other things like they don't
think they could hold still for that
long so I'm not that surprised but
usually there's at least one person
who's like super excited like where can
I sign up so I guess I guess I wasn't
surprised that people were not wanting
to try it but I was surprised that there
wasn't that one who did want to try
maybe we just didn't ask enough people
or maybe they're hiding there like I
work with these people I don't want them
to know why was that you know
would you be willing to try this I love
the little hair thing I'm Jewish I
didn't shoot but I I think this is
really cool I wish I can yeah I think if
I get drunk enough or going to a party
that's the secret
[Music]